[Music]
[Applause]
we're gonna be talking about what is the
greatest keegan-michael key character of
all time the last few weeks we've been
looking at key and Peele and talking
about our favorite sketches and you have
let us know in the comments which ones
we might have missed substitute teacher
keep a look out for that one today but
first watch my pic check it out
I look this woman in the eye said bitch
you told me 6:45 oh you said that I laid
it out would you say a bitch though hmm
he said bitch yeah here's a question is
that sketch problematic now sorry my my
wife is texting me I'm getting buzzes
I'll turn off my Bluetooth I got this I
got this smartphone or a SmartWatch
sorry about that can you yo man wouldn't
do that my lady bro I don't
so don't do that bitch I'm doing my show
should I should I add a bunch of ice
feels more of a joke it's more of a joke
I feel safer doing that no don't do it
[Music]
then it goes away
Oh me on your side so you forget all
this mess you have no context facing I'm
going to text my wife
hi wrote I pooped all over the set this
is a headline keegan-michael key is
going to be on beep I love it I love you
guys want to beep still no response
Oh God okay no more commentary on that
move on next videos from Chris check
this out Jeff let's have a look at the
replay here to see if indeed he did do
the three pumps alright no question
there is the first Yeah right
agreed right and coming up is the second
one okay yes very clear
it's the third we'll see it it's coming
out you hear oh yeah you're right
there's absolutely three pumps there I
used to play football and that just made
me feel good watching that plus I don't
think that third one was actually
official pump
Dooku I mean you gotta you got to base
it off the distance of the pump like you
know I mean like you can't get another
damage down there oh did you have a
gutsy celebration you do I only score
once cuz I was alive and I picked up a
fumble ran it back of me
can we go talk about that though I know
I was out of breath we have maybe now we
could also address the fact that it is
November and you are wearing a Halloween
costume I think you could pull off this
[Music]
what is happening no punctuation she's
so upset she's ever been
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
are you doing yeah just stopping by
just wanna check up on everything okay
[Music]
closet look good door is strong so y'all
said lemme yeah we've been living here a
year and a half so we have so how does
cupboards uh what can I fight you nobody
in here besides of stuff which looks
good
thank you completely unrelated have
y'all seen a four foot eleven dude with
a purple beard up in here what's the
craziest type of label you ever had well
he particularly reminded me of one I had
who shows me and a friend of mine who
was a girl we were living in this
apartment above him and he all of a
sudden like didn't want us to have
guests over like just out of nowhere
yeah no more guests and so whenever
someone else would come to the apartment
he would wait for them so he would he
lived right downstairs and he kept his
door ajar so that if someone came
downstairs that wasn't us he would pop
out and be like you don't live here you
know it's like you're living what do you
like to try to sell your visitor's pass
he I think was successful in getting us
to move out okay we've got one more clip
to watch this one's coming from Jordan
yeah classic you were clamoring for this
one in the comments substitute teacher
Jay Quellin where's Jay Quellin net no
Jay Quellin here do you mean Jacqueline
okay so that's how it's gonna be y'all
want to play okay dear oh come on you
Jake wanna but lucky
where is balakay n-no but lucky here
today yes sir my name is Blake are you
out of your goddamn mind lake what do
you want to go to war balakey cuz we
could go to war no I'm for real I'm for
real so you better check yourself
dee-nice
is there a dee-nice
if one of y'all says some silly-ass name
this whole class is gonna feel my wrath
now dee-nice
do you mean Denise one time I saw the
kid hey Ron
at a party and I like the actor who
plays the actor who plays yeah and
almost like was like oh a Ron but I bet
he gets that a lot
I was cool with the party we headed to
nice in high school we actually called
dee-nice yeah yeah we just it was like
first day of school somebody was like it
was like Denise and I was like you know
Dee nice and it is stuck she was cool as
though all right we're closing our
substitute teacher a very strong
contender for the best keegan-michael
key sketch of all time let us know in
the comments if you think there's any
that we missed hey Chris you got a
shoutout for us yeah I got a shoutout
y'all imma talk my man Stan Klaus
sometimes a monster's inside us why I
had it words there sometimes the
monsters in us know if you added a word
sometimes the monster is us yeah there
you go that's from the Loch Ness
monsters man listen to episode yesterday
about the finding that she was crazy go
check it out check it out thanks for a
comment now mr. Ryan Beck is gonna
interview Paul virzi about his Comedy
Central stand-up special
hey everybody I'm Ryan Beck I'm here
with Paul virzi Paul thanks for being
here thanks for having me
Paul's got a special this Friday at
12:30 on Comedy Central called bill burr
presents Paul virzi I'll say this I'm
telling you right now Donald Trump died
and went to heaven
hey tweet about it you complain about
like it's totally overrated up here okay
Jesus never around bad leadership folks
Melania went back to New York she didn't
like death okay so I've decided to run
for Jesus I'm gonna run for Jesus nobody
will be more Jesus than me right now
we're gonna play a game called before or
after are you ready do it okay so this
is how this works I say a sentence and
you tell me the answer
okay that's usually how it works
yeah all right if the people at home
can't figure it out that's on them just
keep watching the video you'll get to it
the debut of Reno 911 I have an
announcement to make
[Music]
was it before or after Burger King
introduced the chicken fry I'm gonna say
the Burger King chicken fry came first
am I wrong you're wrong ah it's two
years before Reno 911 they brought the
chicken fries out they said everyone
likes french fries what if instead of
potatoes it was me as soon as I heard
the Burger King part of the question
that's where my mind went
I'm like I'm one of those guys or like
I'm like I have an inner fat guy like
I'm like two weeks I'm like two weekends
away like I'm like to binge weekends
away from just blowing out into a mess
yeah our next question the final episode
of key and Peele but you know who I like
as much as Neeson's
as much as Neeson's Oh Bruce Willy is
that before or after the last episode of
Family Guy before it was family guy
still in the air yeah thanks for like
setting me up to sound like the biggest
well if I got that wrong yeah
if I got that wrong you're gonna be back
here with us in this room next question
final episode of colbert report folks if
you watch this show if you're a frequent
watcher of this show and I hope you are
you know I wear many hats pundit
journalists and this one that says I'm a
female body inspector rich due to a
pending court case I legally must inform
you is not an actual governmental
position did it air before after I got a
dog after way before way before I just
got it done January 2017 shoes so I'll
show you pictures I don't I don't know
you
why are you acted on your birthday I
don't know you like you but I don't know
anything about you well you can check
out Paul special this Friday bill burr
presents Paul virzi I'll say this thank
you so much for joining me thanks for
having me I also see Natasha wrote I
pooped all over the set help and then it
followed that up with Keegan his hyung
beat ain't that cool babe oh I'm just
trying to keep her a breast I said what
is happening I'm doing over for this I
think well while it's ringing here's a
picture of me and keegan-michael key so
whatever and you know what here's a
picture of me and Olivia Munn and
sterling K Brown we're all just hanging
out so
it's not looking good bro with some hugs
assignments candies maybe some flowers
I mean hey sweetheart
sorry that I texted earlier and said
that you were a bitch we were just doing
it for a show you know there's that key
and peele sketch I said bitch you can
ice cube the date is Chris yo Chris
Chris cotton says hi we're living this
sketch I love you
talk to you later love you too Miranda
Bree did that help you think
[Music]